bonjour alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous arte france alors c'est pas
vraiment une surprise les français ont
peur les français sont inquiets et vous
ne comprenez oui on peut le comprendre
puisque on voit bien que cette crise
dure le confinement dur et on ne voit
toujours pas arrivé les tests les
masques on a toujours ses injonctions
contradictoires les enfants à l'école le
11 se serait pas très grave le 11 mai
après tout il ne serait pas porter alors
qu'on a fermé les écoles parce que
justement il aurait pu être porteurs
asymptomatiques on ne comprend rien
comme d'habitude la peur en fait c'est
de dire comment on va sortir de ce
capharnaüm comment on va sortir du
confinement comment on va sortir de
cette crise sanitaire à laquelle va
s'ajouter une crise économique est
aujourd'hui la méfiance est de mise
parce qu'on a affaire à des responsables
politiques qui font d'abord de la
communication avant d'agir de
réquisitionner des entreprises de
nationaliser de transformer des chaînes
de production pour produire suffisamment
de mas de tesse de respirateurs et
autres et puis et puis on ne peut pas
leur en vouloir après tout parce que il
ne ferait à peu près comme partout
ailleurs et que c'est pire ailleurs et
donc finalement en france on devrait
être fiers et applaudir des deux mains
une réalité c'est que on ne connaît pas
grand chose de ce virus à la fois sur le
temps d'incubation sur la fabrique
d'anticorps donc c'est ce pari de
l'immunité collective semble impossible
à atteindre et c'est là où ça patauge
c'est que on ne sait pas quoi faire et
qu'un vaccin est encore très loin si
jamais vaccin il devait y avoir
mais c'est justement vous saoule vielles
à l'incertitude la contradiction le voit
pour les seniors on leur dit les plus
fragiles resteront confinées finalement
ils ne resteront pas confiné idem pour
le port du masque on nous dit que c'est
finalement un barrage assez efficace
contre la maladie
et on voit le conseil d'état annule
l'obligation d'en fait par certains
maires là aussi on est dans de la
contradiction
oui parce que on gère la pénurie comme
comme depuis le début c'est à dire que
au début on a menti sur l'importance du
mas sur la façon dont il fallait
répondre et on s'en faire dans ce
mensonge plutôt que de dire on va
changer des choses alors emmanuel macron
dans son discours de lundi a dit j'ai vu
comme vous il se met à notre niveau
c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas responsable
à l'huile et comme nous ils voient que
ça marche pas et quel est son rôle alors
moi j'ai envie de dire mais qui est le
responsable à qui on va parler à quel
moment on va avoir des masques alors on
apprend qu'un avion va arriver avec des
masques on les attend quand même depuis
quelques semaines voire des mois
et donc il va falloir en avoir si on
veut réussir un déconfinement et puis
autre une autre folie c'est comment
penser que une catégorie de la
population devrait rester enfermés
indéfiniment vous avez ursula von der
leyen président du conseil européen qui
pensent que oui les personnes âgées
devraient rester confinées jusqu'à la
fin de l'année mais c'est impossible sa
petite a1 être humain certes il comment
ça fonctionne également la même gestion
catastrophique sur la façon dont on peut
dire au revoir aux proches
allez les voir dans les ehpad quand on a
une personne qui meurt seul très loin il
va falloir aussi changer tout ça parce
qu'on va devoir vivre avec ce virus
qu'on le veuille ou non on va devoir
sortir pour apprendre nos activités et
trouver des moyens de se protéger de
protéger ceux qu'on aime et de revenir à
une vie normale loin de la société du
contrôle qu'on voudrait mettre en place
parce que ce virus est bien pratique
d'une certaine façon pour les
applications de contrôle
les drones de contrôle mais alors pour
ce qui est des masques et des moyens
supplémentaires à l'hôpital
eh bien on va encore attendre longtemps
vous parlez vu du discours du chef de
l'état lundi dernier selon un autre
sondage 62% l'avait pourtant trouvé
convaincant mais une majorité s'est tout
de même sceptique sur la capacité de
l'exécutif à mettre en oeuvre la presle
après confinement c'est contradictoire
non c'est pas contradictoire je pense
que la parole politique est totalement
déconsidéré parce qu'il ya eu trop de
mensonges et que effectivement on peut
entendre un discours c'est toujours bien
mais ce qui compte c'est les actes et en
particulier avec haendel macron souvent
les discours sont loin vous
à l'opposé des actes typiquement il
parle de solidarité européenne et le
groupe renault dont fait partie en
marche via un va voter au parlement
européen contre les cornes à bones
contre une solidarité européenne de fait
il ya des annonces qui sont faites sur
l'aide à l'afrique et puis le lendemain
on parle d'un moratoire à la dette
plutôt que d'annuler la dette
donc on navigue à vue et puis cette
façon de gouverner qui devrait inquiéter
tout le monde dans la solitude dans l'
isolement il n'a prévenu que très peu de
gens autour de son entourage le premier
ministre au lycée vers ans à propos de
la date du 11 mai on ne sait pas d'où
elle sort d'où elle vient
alors il ya peut-être le conseil
scientifique qui est là pour l'aider à
prendre des décisions mais c'est un
grand pays la france ça ne peut pas être
géré depuis le bureau d'un seul homme à
l'elysée il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes
vous l'avez dit sur cette épidémie
néanmoins on le voit nous voisins
l'allemagne la pologne ou l'autriche ont
déjà programmé un déconfinement avec des
mesures très précises
pourquoi la france n'est pas en mesure
de le faire c'est toujours ce manque de
masques et de tests par manque de moyens
we will par manque de moyens absolument
par manque de moyens parce que on est
incapable d'organiser un déconfinement
dans le calme et l'assurance d'une
sécurité maximale pour tous sachant
qu'on va devoir vivre avec ce news je le
répète c'est à dire que quand on va
sortir le virus sera encore là il y aura
d'autres poches le commerce
international va reprendre les voyages
vont reprendre on ne sait pas à quel
horizon mais le monde va être différent
parce que le corps d'un virus va être là
et qu'il y aura d'autres sans doute
d'autres virus la couronne qui risque
d'arriver d'autres pandémies celle ci
est la première donc c'est un peu un
test pour voir comment ça fonctionne or
on voit d'autres pays qui gère beaucoup
mieux parce qu'ils ont un système de
santé qui est mieux préparé parce qu'ils
se sont mieux préparés aussi dans la
façon de gérer les populations et en
france il se tout serait la faute des
français qui seraient incapables de
mettre des masques qui ne savent pas
comment faire mais en même temps
regarder comment les ordres les
injonctions sont contradictoires aux
plus hauts sommets
les pharmaciens qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi ils ne peuvent pas vendre des
masques ou en donner les masques on ne
sait toujours pas où ils sont et le
problème il est là au fond on n'organise
pas une réponse à la hauteur de la crise
au delà des masques un exemple concret
par exemple l'allemagne va rouvrir les
écoles pour les lycées
un mais pas pour les petits la france
fait linverse alors on comprend qu'il ya
des scientifiques mais là on comprend
pas le la méthode la méthode c'est
encore une fois essayé de masquer les
intentions réelles
l'idée c'est que les français doivent
retourner au travail pour aller
travailler et bien on doit pas pour
garder les enfants à la maison donc les
plus jeunes vont aller plutôt qu'à
l'école en garderie et d'ailleurs c'est
c'est à demi mot ce que dit monsieur
blanc caire c'est vrai que ce ne sera
pas l'école qu'on connaît ce sera tout
le monde n'ira pas en même temps avoir
commencé alors la bienveillance ce
serait de dire on évite le décrochage
scolaire on va aider les enfants qui
sont qui ont du mal avec cette façon de
faire une autre réalité c'est on va
délester les parents de la garde
d'enfants pour que eux puis se retourner
travailler dans le secteur non
stratégique parce que la crise
économique sera bien plus graves encore
que la crise sanitaire si on n'aura même
pas l'économie en route et ça c'est un
fait mais c'est difficile à dire c'est
difficile à accepter surtout quand on
n'a pas les capacités de protéger les
populations que ce soit dans les
transports en commun ou sur les lieux de
travail ou ailleurs au sein des familles
c'est à dire qu'un enfant qui ramènerait
le virus au sein de la de la famille
bien c'est l'assurance d'une deuxième
vague edouard philippe doit doit prendre
la parole à nouveau demain il avait été
très pédagogique on s'en souvient lors
de sa première intervention avec le
ministre de la santé
à quoi faut-il s'attendre selon vous
demain sans doute un peu plus de
chiffres un peu plus de précisions sur
les aides qui vont être apportées aux
entreprises aux ménages sans doute aussi
un peu plus d'éclaircissements sur ce
retour progressif à l'école du 11 mai
cette date du 11 mai ce qu'elle est
réaliste est ce qu elle n est un jalon
super d'autres dates d'autres ouvertures
et on espère oui quelque chose de
beaucoup plus concret que ce qui a été
annoncé lundi on a l'impression d'un
discours d'un monarque qui disent je
décide et puis la tendance suivra donc
là on va avoir le discours de
l'intendance qui va dire comment elle va
suivre
de quelle façon le l'état va s'organiser
pour répondre à ces demandes
et si c'est possible et il y aura c'est
un exercice de communication politique
encore une fois l'avion va arriver
chargé de masse mais les faits sont
têtus
nous avons encore besoin de davantage au
mas de distribution on ne les voit pas
de test on veut savoir combien comment
et puis d'organisation de reprise
économique oui à laquelle horizons et de
quelle façon
merci beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france